hello everybody
in this video i'm going to tell you a
bit more about the ongoing auditors
competition for which you can still
register until the 12th of april
now you may have seen on our website on
the landing page of this competition
this particular infographic which shows
you basically in a nutshell
what the different stages are in this
competition
in one blink of an eye
now i will give you a bit more in-depth
information on these different steps
of this infographic all right
so the eligibility criteria first you
need this is an ad7 competition so you
need
a degree being a master's degree
plus six years of experience in the
field
or a bachelor's degree with seven years
of experience in the field
and that experience must be in one of
the
fields that is mentioned below
as you can see audit economics finance
statistics mathematics
data analysis computer engineering or
data mining this has to be the topic of
your work
experience
if you are legible you can apply and
then you see here on this slide at the
different steps of the competition i
will go in in detail in each of them
first there will be of course the
application phase
then there's a first testing stage
then there's a second testing stage
which is the assessment center and once
you've completed that your name if you
are successful will be placed on a list
of people to recruit by the court of
auditors in luxembourg
so let's have a closer look on these
different steps the application goes
through your epso account so you should
have
or you should create an epso account if
you don't have one yet
once you have created your account log
out of it and then go back to our home
page of the website basically where you
can start your application by clicking
on the
audit entry
as i said you can still apply until 12
april 2022
noon brussels time
you have to fill out your application
form in your first language now the
first language is a choice of the 24
official eu languages up to you to
choose which one you you choose
most people take their monotone but you
don't have to if you feel fluid fluent
enough in another language you can
choose any of the 24 available
part of the application process
is already the talent screener which is
the first stage of the testing but you
already
fill out this stage in the application
here
now that part the talent screener part
must be filled out in your second
language
and the second language for this
competition is a choice between either
english or french okay
once you've done that you validate your
application in time and then the first
testing really starts so as i said you
have already completed the talent
screener part this is a set of nine
questions
to basically assess your qualifications
we see which degrees you have which work
experience you have in which fields how
much how long all that
it's a set of nine questions and each
questions question has a certain weight
and you can gain a number of points per
question and of course the best ones the
ones with the most points make it to the
next stage
how many people we invite to the next
stage depends on the number of
successful people that we want to select
through this competition and that number
is 60. so we will invite a maximum of
180
people to the next stage of testing okay
this next stage is part of what we call
the assessment center in the assessment
center we have three different stages or
the three different tests
the first test is a reasoning skills
test
and you see on this slide the number of
questions we ask you the time allocated
to solve these questions
and the points you need
to make it to the next phase basically
for this competition we need you to get
a combined pass mark
of at least 30 out of 50. so you can
fail in one or more
of these reading skills as long as
combined you reach at least 30. okay
this stage is an important stage so i do
advise you to test this to train this
and you can do so on our website we have
sample tests available in all 24
languages
to train these reading skills
because as you can see here it's not
only about the difficulty of the
questions
but there's also this time factor
involved and this makes that you have to
solve these questions in a limited
amount of time which makes it harder to
do
by training this by you know doing this
often you get better at this so please
go to the link
which you see on this slide here and try
this okay
the ones who
reach the past mark they are invited to
the next stage
and the next stage is a couple of
interviews
first of all there's a field related
interview so we test your knowledge in
the field and you need at least 120
points out of 200 so you see this is an
important test because you can get up to
200
points here
you sit this test in your second
language the one you used to fill out
the talent screener so either english or
french
and then we make you sit
two more interviews
to assess your general competencies
first we tested your knowledge in the
field now we're going to test your
general competencies
there's a first interview which we call
the
the competency based interview and there
we test four general competencies you
see them listed here on this slide
you can get 10 points per
per competency
and
combined with the next test which is the
situational competency based interview
you need at least a combined pass mark
of 40 out of 80 because
this situational competency based
interview tests for other general
competencies
also listed on this slide here so we've
got eight competencies in total you can
gain up to 10 points per competency and
you need at least 40 out of 80 combined
again you can fail some but then you
have to perform better on others okay
the situational competency based
interview is basically an interview
where we put you in a certain situation
a work-related situation
and we want to see how you would react
in that given situation that's the
difference with the normal
competency based interview okay
so the best ones make it to the list of
successful candidates and we're looking
for 60
auditors to recruit and the institution
recruiting these 60 auditors will be the
european court of auditors which is
located in luxembourg
so what happens next is as soon as this
list is published the court of orders
will get in touch with
the people on the list and offer them a
position in the months after publication
of that list
so then you can start working
quite soon after that
i hope this is clear
if you have any questions you can always
reach out to us through the contact form
on our website and my colleagues will be
very happy to answer your questions
thank you for your attention and good
luck bye